[Musique]
rencontres du premier type cloud simple
phénomène naturel en tout cas des
centaines et des centaines de
témoignages pour décrire hier le même
phénomène un drôle de triangle lumineux
qui a traversé un peu après 19 heures
une bonne partie de la france et une
partie de l'europe les spécialistes ont
tenté depuis ce matin d'expliquer cette
apparition
c'est dominique dumas qui a enquêté sur
cet objet volant non identifié comme sur
ce document on aurait voulu y croire
une formation triangulaire lumineuse
semblable à un gigantesque cerf-volant
était observé par des dizaines de
personnes
hier vers 19 heures des témoignages
enregistrés à plusieurs centaines de
kilomètres de distance en bretagne en
région parisienne dans le sud-ouest de
la france sur la riviera italienne et en
alsace ma voiture et j'ai en gardant le
sale et qu'est ce que je vois j'ai
l'impression que c'était des avions qui
est en manoeuvre donc en triangle et ce
qui m'étonnait pourtant c'est que j'ai
entendu aucun bruit dont je me suis dit
oh alors il faut la très haute altitude
alors je les verrai pas donc ça ne
paraissait pas logique et après je me
suis longtemps c'est peut-être des
étoiles filantes mais combien y avait
presque une dizaine de disques en masse
et sexuelle j'ai fais un voeu et puis
aussi dit on verra bien suite à ces
informations je me suis renseigné au
centre de contrôle civil de reims qui
lui m'a fait savoir que quelques pilotes
avaient signalé des phénomènes bizarres
mais j'ai pas eu plaidé détails hélas
pour les amateurs de soucoupe
l'observatoire de munich vient
d'annoncer qu'il s'agirait de météores
déjà à paris l'aviation civile ce matin
étaient sceptiques pensant aussi à des
débris de satellite ou à des météorites
tant pis pour les petits hommes verts
toujours attendu sur la planète bleue
[Musique]